I'm a driver I'm a flier the waited a
long time for a shot like this would
people grow up watching Star Wars that
no Star Wars but then you're seeing
behind the curtain it's very Wizard of
Oz all of a sudden that you're
surrounded but in the year these in
these incredible worlds with all these
aliens and creatures and everybody The
Creature Shop is kind of an unbelievable
place which is where all the puppeteers
and engineers are building all their
yeah that's yeah and then they're
building all the aliens and everybody
and then there's like a wookie room
where everybody's sitting sewing
individual yak hairs and all the wookie
suits we showed it in double-a seven
stage and Pinewood some one of the
biggest stages in Europe and it was they
used the whole thing the whole space
just one big room one big set and so
you're kind of walking through being
like her man good acting you would act
like on acts i'm steve i heard a story
about you i was wondering if it's true
everything is right about me
it's true
I know Billy Dee talked to you about
this role and his advice was to be
charming
this how do you be charming can you give
the audience out there are some tips and
me some tips on how to be charming how
do you turn on the charm I know there
was a scene that George came to set that
he influenced or he he gave somebody a
note and it changed the scene what was
the scene the first day of shooting he
came by it I'd heard you might stop by
and we were watching heshes nothing but
supportive and he just leaned over to me
at one point he said you know what hon
would really do there I've been holding
back you know what he'd really do it
wasn't a massive change but it was
suddenly just gave it that Han Solo
flavor and it was a real reminder that
yeah we all think of Harrison Ford as it
relates to you know Han Solo but Han
Solo is a character created by George
it's not just something that's visually
stunning it's also really compelling on
in like an emotional level big sci-fi
special-effects movies bang-bang-bang
you you're kind of disconnected from it
because of those things but it was all
about character so last night there was
somebody at the premiere that had the
Chewbacca costume on and I hugged him
and I could feel the sweat for me his
costume was that your life that has been
my life for for for however many months
we film it was extremely hot and one of
the thing is to the hairspray the suit
so much to keep it contained that it
smells wonderful from the outside
that's yes I'm asking everybody to do
Chewbacca voice today can you do a
Chewbacca voice because you know what it
is love it's taken me a long time to
achieve dignity defender in my life and
I just don't want to give it up in two
seconds like that I know I didn't but I
was trying to say Fandango it comes from
deep within it really did hokey heart
[Music]
a hundred and ninety years old feel
great
[Music]
you